buenas tardes se prepara con mucha
logística y medidas de seguridad para
recibir un número de público tan grande
que en londres no ha visto en toda su
historia el martes en la tarde será
trasladado el cuerpo de isabel segunda
en un avión de la fuerza armada
británica inicialmente al palacio de
buckingham en el centro de la capital
donde permanecerá hasta el miércoles por
la tarde cuando será trasladado en una
ceremonia militar en una procesión por
las principales calles de londres del
centro de londres hasta el palacio de
westminster que es el parlamento ahí
tendrá un pequeño y corto
celebración festejo religioso y
posteriormente entonces se abrirá las
puertas del parlamento al público para
que se puedan rendir tributos personales
por cuatro días el lunes será entonces
el funeral de ésta y ya desde ya se
están entregando los tiquetes para que
los miembros del público puedan asistir
a esta celebración a este a este último
adiós que se espera rendir a isabel 2a
por cuatro días en la capital británica
como lo mencionas en este momento del
cuerpo de la reina isabel segunda va
camino a edimburgo miles y miles de
personas han salido a las verdes
regiones de escocia a darle un último
adiós a la reina isabel segunda que
tenía un cariño muy especial justamente
por escocia